All right, here is how I did it. I go through the first step, miles driven is
50,000. The first miles per gallon is 10. So, that's 5000. The price per gallon
is 4. 5000 times 4 is 20,000. Now moving on to the next step, the purchase
price for the first car is 15,000 plus the 20,000. From over here, gets my
total cost of 35000 over the life time of the car. With the second car, again
we drive a 50000 miles. Now the miles per gallon is 50. 50000 over 50 is a 1000
times 4 because we have $4 per gallon, is 4,000 for the gas cost. The purchase
price was 30,000, plus the gas cost 4,000 gets me to 34,000. Now let's go on
with the algorithm, is total cost one less than total cost two? No it's not,
35,000 is bigger than 34,000. So the algorithm tells us to buy car two. Well,
what a relief. I never wanted to buy that one in the first place. But now I
have a procedure that is unambiguous, executable, and terminating that tells me
what car to buy. So, this is a great example of an algorithm It is a recipe of
steps each of which is so simple that a computer or a human can execute them
and it reaches an answer. Now, you will notice that this algorithm here was
written up in some mixture of plain English and Math not in Java code or not in
any other computer language. This is called Pseudocode, and Pseudocode is
really important. When you want to develop an algorithm before you get to coded
up in Java or another programming language. What most programmers do when they
need to solve a complex problem is they first get out a sheet of paper and
describe the problem in Pseudocode and then they write in Java. Pseudocode
doesn't have anyway near as many rules as Java does, but so it's a good idea to
restrict oneself to simple constructs in Psuedocode. Let me show you what those
would be.